I have a show that I'm filming in the
summer comedy Camp let me tell you about
that no
it's happening it's a show that I'm I'm
ready where you take comedians camping I
take comedian you ever see the show
alone
no all right there's a show called alone
and they take 10 people up into the
woods
and they drop them off three miles five
miles seven miles apart from each other
and whoever lasts the longest wins oh
this show is I'm taking five comedians
up into the woods
and for five days
but there's no it's literally hiking up
into the mountains
making a camp and living for five days
with five comedians that's gonna be
tough it's gonna be tough and this is
based on the thing you do with Ari and
Joe list it's based on it's kind of
Bushcraft party boys and what do you
guys do again you go into like the
waywards we
love that you talk about like yes you go
up into the woods I've never been
invited I'm I'm an alien dude I would
take you out we'll do it this summer
yeah but yeah we're filming it yeah we
should do it Russell Peters is an island
but you can't do the woods in Long
Island there's no Hills there's no Hills
it's a [ __ ] flat place there's enough
Hills there's no mountains
just Cliffs there's no you can't
Bushcraft in a cliff Tim okay you can't
so Russell Peters is doing this Russell
Peters Bill Burr okay Jim Norton
okay you got a group we got uh Beth
Stallings hopefully she's doing it and
we're we're literally you should get
Whitney in there Whitney he'll kill Olia
wouldn't it be great I mean it should be
fantastic but I mean no cell phones no
internet no managers no nothing no how
do you shoot the show Crafts everybody
it's like the show alone everybody has
the cameras on them
and we have a a one a camera person
that's shooting
people are gonna die Bobby
people are gonna die what are you
talking about people what do you mean
what am I talking about people are gonna
die nobody's going to die you're gonna
have blood on your hands We're not gonna
have blood all over your hands should be
dripping off your hands what are you
talking about people are gonna die how
are they gonna die not able to you're
not able to survive in these conditions
listen it's not going to be we're going
to have supplies okay so now we get to
the real well hang on let's get to the
reality listen we're going to have
supplies not like they're gonna have to
hunt for their food okay see they show
up and they have a tent and food they
have to well first of all do you they
have to set up their Camp they have they
have to set up they have to we have to
it's it's called Uh primitive camping so
we there's no campsite it's not about
glamping where it's glamorous no okay no
no no no it's it's primitive camping so
you we're hiking up into a certain place
we have a guide that's going to take us
well I have will you have a Coleman tent
you'll have a uh a tarp
okay you'll have a tarp and
disperse camping but you're yes you're
gonna turn giving to camping in the
United States on public land other than
designated campsites this type of
camping is most common National Forest
so this is the type of stuff we're gonna
basically hike up four hours into the
woods find a spot make camp and you'll
have to do certain tasks
start a fire get firewood uh uh have a
solo night out by yourself you're gonna
have to like Norton's gonna have to go
out into the woods
we're going to find a place set up a
camp build a structure to protect
himself
and sleep out by himself at night I'll
ask a question yes sir
why and because
you have I mean have you ever been out
in the woods I have have you ever known
what's your evil
it's true they're Pagan I I'm a
Christian I believe in the oceans and
the mansions and the rolls royces
because I'm a Christian I'm a follower
of Christ the woods are pagan and
satanic I don't love the woods the woods
are beautiful and quiet and it's one of
the only places you can go where you can
go back in time to where it was a much
simpler place where you are not with
your addictions you're not with your
compulsions you're not with this
excitement or huge highs or really lows
it's just good
I do enjoy I will say it is a nice
campfire and some stuff is fun there's
nothing like being out with no phone
could I bring like a Bush's Baked Bean
like the grilling beans you if you do
the show if you do it of course you okay
I'll allow you baked beans for one night
but okay so everybody because you're
saying that they're not gonna have to
hunt for their food well we're gonna
look into that because if because well
if we could uh set you're gonna have to
we could set snares for certain things
or fish uh fishing is going to be a big
thing yeah Russell Peters by the way has
like 19 Bentleys does he know he'll be
snaring the food or you don't know
Russell peters's background I'm sure is
it in India and does it involve water
that's not clean it involves Tigers yeah
I get it he's done the father used to
hunt tigers that's nuts and he went with
him as a boy
and and actually will you be camping
where there are tigers no this is gonna
be no time okay there's gonna be no
target but there it's gonna be Wildlife
man this is fun that's gangster that's
him man that tiger
he's shot as it was jumping up to kill
him
well I'm against the murder of the uh
the animals like well over there you you
know I get it because they're coming to
the Village so yeah that's what the
environmentalists don't realize they
come into the village and snatch kids
and monkeys are thieves yes yeah yeah
but yes this is gonna be it's gonna be
to take a Norton Jim Norton out and take
him out of the penthouse the cabs the
car the cell phones all the stuff that
all sounds great and to put him up in
the woods
five days five is a lot Bobby well
there's one up one up and one down okay
three it's well uh probably four days
then I would say I would say six days
it's coming down so you're gonna have
four days up in the woods okay so so we
have to set up camp you have to you know
doing Upstate New York it's either gonna
be in Upstate New York or it's gonna be
in Canada in Toronto oh so it's it's
gonna be crazy man because when the Sun
goes down like I I've gone up with
people like me and Ari and Joe have gone
up I've taken Paul verzi up in the woods
just me and him you hike up a couple
hours you you make a spot and then
you're having a good time and then the
sun goes down and the whole world
changes now explain that because that
sounds very gay and very cool yeah we
just
sucking each other off because there's
nobody around when you say the sun goes
down and the whole world
[Music]
that sounds like the gayest thing I've
ever heard
no dude it's now when you see this
because it gets dark does it when it
gets dark out in the woods you
understand like in the city you can't
see stars right because the lights of
the city but when you go out in the
woods there's no lights of the city so
that you can see galaxies [ __ ]
turning you know what I mean yeah no I
do know it's a different thing and but
you can't see in front of your face and
then your eyes adjust and all of a
sudden you're in complete darkness the
only thing you have is the fire
and there's nobody around for two hours
and when you hear something it's
something right it's not nothing right
it's something right and you have to
deal with that you're describing the
Bronx
it's very similar yeah okay
you have the same fears yeah what do you
see happen to people you've done this
before what happens on that second or
third day when there is no shrimp scampi
or quesadilla what happens to these guys
what do they become you you become like
you you get you become
um a truer version of yourself no you be
you you you actually get to be yourself
interesting you actually become yourself
interesting because you you're actually
looking at things and appreciating them
and when you get back to your house and
the the AC's on and your pillows are on
the bed and you open a fridge
and you you you you
have you ever thought of doing it would
you take Comics to the Bronx
and you put them and the night falls and
they have to set up a can it's the same
show but it's just easier to shoot
because it's in them it's too dangerous
it's it's I understand what you mean and
I feel like what but I I do love the
beach and the ocean and that to me is
right to walk on the beach
what's gonna attack you a middle-aged
[ __ ] gay guy trying to suck you off
no that's more dangerous to many people
you know than a lion first of all
tigers are much easier to deal with than
Jews so if you were on a beach
if you were on a beach in the Hamptons
my whole point is that like their nature
isn't just the woods it's not just the
woods the ocean's tough I've been in
Riptides I've almost died in Riptides
have you ever been in a Riptide I've
been in a [ __ ] rear you swim diagonal
yeah I didn't know that at the time but
the point is nobody knows that yo I
didn't know it but you're right and you
they have lifeguards that [ __ ]
everywhere I not where I am I did down
in Southampton is a commonwealth the
ocean is a [ __ ] is is I don't like it
it's not fun it's more powerful than the
woods you know it is
you know the ocean's more powerful than
the woods the feminine is more powerful
than the masculine and you know it the
ocean's big [ __ ] okay fine I will give
you that the ocean is more powerful than
the woods but the woods the woods are
better
no the woods are better no 100 no dude
the ocean is the same [ __ ] every day
because it's dope dude
we have seasons in the forest I do so I
do like the idea of that are you
thinking about is this a fall thing it's
got It's Gonna be in the spring because
we gotta go after mud season because
when the winter after the winter the
mountains
um the snow melts and and the woods
become very muddy and then there's fly
Seasons bug season when the bugs all
hatch that's the summer and you don't
well that's the beginning of the summer
there's a certain time when the black
flies is that you don't want to be in
the woods at that time it's a nightmare
during the day so we gotta we want to go
uh either in the spring or the late
summer you know uh now September is a
good time to go because there's no bugs
it's cold at night and uh you know we
wanted to we don't want it to be too hot
we don't want it to be too [ __ ] up
because I don't want to break these guys
I don't want them well that's what I I
thought you were gonna do well let me
tell you something dude you know the the
winner of it you know you win by you
know doing certain tasks well you know
uh so you get certain you get what would
you what would a task be like sucking
someone off
can that be a task
wow
it's gonna be interesting
oh that's
you're gonna get Girl Scout patches okay
like a sash you're gonna have a sash
yeah and whoever completes the most
tasks
um
and you know they they we're gonna give
money to charity I'm paying for all this
this is [ __ ] awesome yeah the money's
going to charity so that as people what
kind of Charity you take the homeless
people whatever to the woods no whatever
they
whatever they want like it'll be the
person's charity oh nice so they'll pick
the charity but yeah like starting a
fire yeah see this is gonna be listen
this is gonna be very interesting and I
think it's gonna it's gonna someone will
die but that's okay
No No One's Gonna Die oh someone will
die No One's Gonna Die Why is somebody
gonna die because it just it seems like
a lot of things it could kill someone
yeah there's a lot of things that can
kill somebody but I don't think you
should I think you should lean into
someone dying you want the show to be a
show it should be where one person
someone gets sacrificed somebody should
who do you think would die out of that
mix who's the mix again bill
repeaters
bathroom nor me
it'd be funnier if it was you only
because then only because they would
then it would be like if someone else
had shown them
and then that person might would you
take it over if I die
no well it would depend
I would I would feel you know I don't
know you could do it on the beach you
could do like a campfire on the beach at
night it like here's my variety kid
here's my version of the show yeah
here's my version all right let me hear
five comedians we all go to the shore
yeah sure the ocean yeah we swim out
with the great whites yeah [ __ ]
dangerous yeah come back in yeah we get
[ __ ] fish sandwiches we could [ __ ]
Mr Softy yeah we let up Carvel we
[ __ ] relax
do a bonfire on the beach so bonfire on
the beach yeah maybe let's play a little
football yeah Night Football yeah have a
little fun we don't need to we don't
need to go into the woods like nuts
kind of capital Riot show is this will
you come with me this summer I will do
it no I actually I got jealous when you
went with Ari and Joe I would love to go
and experience this will you can you
hike of course I can all right relax I'm
just asking Ike I can hike all right so
this summer
you'll be in New York me and you will go
on an overnight you know we could go go
to the Mohawk Mountain House what's that
you ever be there it's a big Wilderness
Lodge no we're not five star chefs why
oh no they give you picnic baskets you
can go out and eat